our various generous sponsors
particularly Roger hertog and the
Saltzman Institute who have been such
tremendous host for this event
throughout the summer and to remind you
that our final lecture in this series
will take place next week in place same
time when John Lewis gatos joins us
we're extraordinarily lucky tonight in
who we have speaking to us John Mueller
is the has perhaps the best title in all
of academics the woody hair Woody Hayes
national security chair at the Merchant
Center at Ohio State University perhaps
he could tell us a little bit about how
he got that chair and what might be
required behind it but John Mueller has
been a scholar who has not only written
important books but has altered and
shaped debate at several points in his
career about topics of extraordinary
importance in the 1970s he wrote a
path-breaking book called War presidents
in public opinion the 1980's he wrote a
book that had an extraordinary influence
on my own thinking about these questions
the obsolescence of major war several
years ago he wrote a book called
overblown how politicians and the
Terrorism industry and played national
security threats and why we believe them
that as I'm sure you can imagine from
that title cause no shortage of
controversy and discussion and he's here
tonight to talk to us about his most
recent book atomic obsession nuclear
alarmism from Hiroshima to al-qaeda John
Mueller is one of the most thoughtful
provocative and interesting
intellectuals out there today and we are
very lucky to have him
here tonight so please join me in
welcoming here to her tog into the
Columbia thanks very night very much
it's really nice to be here I'd like to
try to be reasonably brief so we have
plenty of time for questions and
comments and expressions of outrage
toward the end i should say at the
beginning that nothing i say should be
taken necessarily to reflect a view of
Woody Hayes or or of any there's
football players particularly the bigger
ones the as Frank mentioned the genesis
in many respects of I mean let me take
you back a little bit and I'd like to
talk about three books actually the book
I wrote him to came out 2006 called
overblown basically arguing to terrorism
the threat of terrorism was massively
exaggerated and it's actually somewhat
broader than that because one of the
main areas of concern and interest to me
was the fact that national security
threats as the subtitle suggests have
been generous since world war two have
been generally exaggerated the threat of
the Soviet Union the threat of communist
domestically the thread of what I call
devils du jour like sukarno or Nasser
oars Kadafi or Saddam Hussein has been
substantially exaggerated and so what I
what I could argue that we know what
happened with these threats each of them
in retrospect clearly was exaggerated
and now we're wallowing and concerned
about terrorism and it looks like the
same thing is happening obviously I
can't be sure how terrorism is going to
turn out though I do know how the Cold
War trip turned out anyway I gave it a
lot of talks on this and i must say that
when i started working doing that i
expected to be lynched but what I'd
mostly found his audiences are really
quite supportive they didn't always
agree of course and that was not
surprising but there was a fair amount
of agreement and thinking that we should
think about this more carefully but I
got two questions that we're basically
like this I agree with everything you
say but what if they get nuclear weapons
and the other is I agree with everything
you say but what do you propose for
policy specifically so both this
question I thought really good ones and
the book the book does deal with both of
those issues in various ways but I
thought clearly I could do a lot more
with that so the book Ibini i'll be
talking about today which is atomic
obsession is the answer to the first
question but if they get nuclear weapons
it's considerably broader as the title
suggests and as i'll be showing you
shortly but it deals not only with
nuclear terrorism but also with the
whole thinking of nuclear weapons
arguing that they really haven't been
dead terribly significant the second
question which is the be a subject of
the book i'll be coming out with a
co-written book with Mark Stewart it was
a engineer and risk analyst at the
University of Newcastle in Australia who
saw me on television and said hey I'm
writing the same kind of stuff so he was
visiting Ohio State at the time in the
engineering department and so he got
together and we did a bunch of papers
and now it's going to come out as this
book probably next April more or less
for the 10th anniversary of 911 and what
we're trying to do is really be very
specific about about the risks and we're
trying to do is apply standard accepted
risk analysis techniques and
cost-benefit techniques ones it have
been accepted by governments and
regulatory agencies for decades and used
and applied and required if basically if
you come into the new vaccine you have
to do risk analysis you know how much is
going to cost how much how much good is
it going to do and so forth if you come
in with you know what you want to cite a
nuclear power plant some place you have
to be the same sort of thing if you have
a new safety device that might save
lives you have to explain how many lies
is going to save what's the risk how
does it change there is any just
standard stuff so we're trying to just
apply that now the terrorism generally
and I what I'd like to do which is very
briefly talk about 22 aspects of that
one is the idea of acceptable risk but
what has happened it's not clear you
know what what risks are acceptable not
acceptable but there's an
now a huge track record for people
working in this area to to look at to
look at risks and what happens is
certied my eyes glass over phenomenon
essentially if a risk is no excuse me i
meant to put this by the way this is a
thing from overblown to statements which
are completely true one is the chances
of any of us dying in a terrorist
incident is very very very small and the
other is no one sees the world like that
on 60 minutes in 2003 at any rate one of
the things you'd want to do is try to
figure out what the likelihood is of
being killed by a terrorist and there's
a lot of ways of doing that and under
present circumstances your chance have
been killed by a terrorist over an
eight-year life period assuming there's
another 911 every several years or some
place in the world outside of war zones
your chance of being killed is about one
in 85,000 not per year but for 80 years
if there aren't another 911s in other
words terrorism continues more or less
the way it has both before and after 911
but not that spectacular outlier doesn't
get repeated then your chance of being
killed if you live outside of war zone
is about one in a hundred and thirty
thousand so we're trying to we're trying
to look at that in context those kinds
of statistics and what you get basically
is the idea of acceptable risk beginning
at the opposite end however this is
unacceptable risk i hope it's readable
in this light but essentially your
chance of dying from cancer in the
united states i think the numbers are
for you is about one in 500 per year
another's one out of every five hundred
Americans dies from cancer per year well
everybody can say that that's you know
that's not acceptable we really want
that to be lower and so it's a huge
amounts of money of course is spent on
cancer research and trying to deal with
that particular problem another thing
would be traffic accidents which is the
fifth one down there I guess and your
chance of being killed in an automobile
accident is by one and a teeth out one
in eight thousand per year that also is
unacceptable and so therefore efforts a
huge amounts of money are being yet
spent on
getting better cars putting seat belts
in cars making highways better and so
forth in other words from a regulator
standpoint the government standpoint all
these kinds of risks are bad enough so
that it's worth worrying about doing
something about things which are at the
top of the end other things you really
want to worry about and that don't the
bottom some but less so but generally
speaking when you get something about
the way people have operated if the
chance of being killed is one in a
hundred thousand or worse then generally
that's considered to be unacceptable
risk we ought to do something about
trying to make that lower spend money on
it the next level is what might be
called accept that acceptable risk but
tolerable risk perhaps somewhere between
this is all sort of just again going
with what practices actually happen is
that if if the risk is between one and a
hundred thousand and one in a million
then that's not as dangerous obviously
but you probably want to spend some time
thinking about that for example drowning
in a bathtub is that their de chance
about one in a million dying per year
and at that point you're beginning to
get people who really don't want to
really think we should do much about it
I mean one possibility obviously is to
ban all bathtubs this has not been a
common popular proposal so when you
start getting to one in a million toward
it then people say well you know it's
not you know that's pretty good and then
beyond that is those risks which are
often basically considered to be
acceptable namely your chance of being
killed is less than one in a million and
again that's basically regulators have
have seen it over although there's
exceptions and not everything is
perfectly smooth and terrorism generally
falls in that area unless you live like
in Northern Ireland or enter in Israel
during the intifada for example but for
the United States or Canada for Britain
including Britain which obviously has a
terrorism problem with some magnitude
the chance of being killed per year are
one in several million and the so they
vary so it's down there Bo more or less
with lightning so in many respects then
what happens is that for terrorism to be
unacceptable in other words to reach the
one in a hundred thousand category or
so you'd have to have one 911 every year
in the United States for example it so
consequently from from the standpoint of
most research of the terrorism is an
acceptable risk that is to say it's not
worth spending a lot of money to lower
the risk or to put it another way if
you're spending money on reducing the
terrorism risk you're not spending it on
things which can do a lot both save a
lot more lives like cancer research or
improving on automobile accidents anyway
that's one thing we're doing the other
is this which I can go fairly briefly I
think the question is how many we're
doing sort of what sort of a cost a
break-even approach it's called we don't
so much estimate as what a terrorist
likelihood is but question is if we're
spending this money to reduce the
likelihood or consequences of terrorist
attack how many attacks are there have
to be to justify the expenditures okay
if you're worried about the time that
they these are losses from a terrorist
attack if the times square bomber had
been successful and he seems been mostly
exercising a former parody as far as I
can see but anyway if you've been
successful the costs of that tragedy
would have been maybe a hundred million
dollars it would have killed some people
there's ways of evaluating human lives
which is again standard procedure and
there be property damage and every
disruption of there being increase of
fear and they'd be a disruption tourism
and so forth and a reasonable estimate
would be too because one hundred million
dollars for the expenditures at the
United States is putting out it enhanced
expenditures to deal with those kinds of
problems there would have to be nearly
sixty to be happy over 1600 attacks like
that per year several every day for that
for it to be cost effective if you go
down the list the the five billion
dollar attack was basically that's what
was caused would have in London the July
seventh 2005 attack about five billion
dollar damage including life property
loss of tourism economic impact indirect
and so forth and forth for a lot that's
a very big attack very rare very own
usual but you need 33 of those a year in
the united states that one every two
weeks in order to justify the
expenditures now the things that do
justify the expenditures are like losses
of one trillion or five trillion if a 1
trillion dollar attack would be a
nuclear it emon get nuclear weapons to
get into that level 1 trillion dollar
attack a terrorist dropping a setting
off a bomb in a harbor for example Long
Beach California would probably cause
about a trillion dollars worth of damage
not all that much in lives lost because
they aren't there any people at the port
but in disruption of traffic and fallout
and in health problems and fear and so
forth in that case you'd need only one
attack every six years of that sort
which doesn't see new you terribly
likely but nonetheless it would start to
make some sense and a five trillion
dollar attack is sort of the top thing
you can do it with the terrorists
setting off a bomb at grand central
terminal which would kill lots of people
and if if you if you get into that level
then it's something you really want to
spend a lot of time worrying about so
consequently the probabilities become
very important under those circumstances
and that's just sort of a sketch of it
but to tie it into the rest of the talk
for terrorism to really become something
that's worth spending this kind of money
on in the United States you'd pretty
much have to have terrorists who are
massively more capable and they probably
have to get nuclear weapons to commit
the kind of damage that would justify
the amount of money we're spending
trying to disrupt to deter and the end
delay waylay various attacks and in the
country so let me turn now to atomic
obsession and the and the by sort of
take on nuclear weapons this is a
statement by Charles Gibson ABC News on
the fifth anniversary of 911 it's fairly
typical of things you get constantly in
the media now putting your child on a
school bus or driving across a bridge or
just going to the mall each of those
things as a small act of courage in
peril is a part of everyday life I have
now basically been relating malls
because they said I can't stand to be
among all those
Rose walking around you know going
through the lingerie and eating hot dogs
and running up and down whatever anyway
but that kind of sanctimonious stuff has
been totally common to give you a
somewhat backtrack a little bit but to
let in that context the only official
who has ever said what I've said namely
your chance of being killed by
terrorists about like the same as being
killed by lightning was mayor bloomberg
here in 2007 that's the only time
they've been able to find any official
who has said that now that's basically
true you may say is some people did well
that's you know he's scared of lightning
too but anyway no one no official no DHS
document no president no congressman no
senator no DHS official has ever said
that to it put it in context they just
let it they just it just never comes up
they're free to say it somehow
apparently okay let me give you a quick
outline of my reasonably quick talk I
hope I want to talk about three things
having to do with nuclear weapons the
first two in particular are highly
relevant to this series one is I think
their historical impact has been
unimpressive in terms of proliferation
of nuclear weapons I think the problem
is basically unproblematic and the case
of nuclear terrorism I think it's just
wildly unlikely so let me lay those out
briefly and they're going to contradict
some of the things you heard from
obviously other people in this series in
fact you can contradict almost about any
but everything everybody else pretty
much says okay let me talk about the
first one also to set that a little bit
in context is to get people like Robert
Gates talking about how every secretary
defence of course every senior leader
when you're asked about what keeps you
awake at night it's basically terrorism
again going to happen you get people
like Robert Muller the head of the FBI
has the same problem you can't sleep
either they're dark circles under his
eyes heavy little brown eyes and the
others of the words nuclear device units
as brows and cleanses teeth the is left
eyebrow shoots like an arrow
so for boys the mid flight I didn't I
didn't make any of that up so we got
Robert Muller who can't sleep and has
problems with his eyebrows and we also
have a CIA investigator Ralph mowatt
Larson who used to be at the CIA and is
now moved to cambridge massachusetts at
Harvard so he's gone from one center of
sustained hysteria Washington DC to the
second one which is Cambridge
Massachusetts and I expect him to show
up any day now on the third center of
sustained hysteria which obviously be
the weather channel in which in which
each you know they probably of a weekly
program called Ralph mullet Larson talks
about this week's storm of the century
anyway he's very worried as well and
this is another quote from someone who's
looking at him carefully he knows surely
with each passing moment we are without
without moles that al-qaeda was looking
for uranium and could get them would
never see it coming that's why he can't
sleep again he's growing grim and
sepulcro and he hasn't touched his corn
muffin so I'm trying to bring good news
so that were also be able to eat a
little bit and perhaps people sleep
better in Washington okay the first
thing then basically is the imprint the
impact of historical weapons the my
argument basically is the nuclear
weapons are awesome but hardly
apocalyptic their destructive capacity
has been commonly exaggerated that
doesn't mean there aren't bad it's just
that we had this sort of idea this is a
phrase that was by spencer where two did
a book called nuclear fear you say
nuclear bomb and everybody immediately
thinks at the end of the world this is a
picture of hiroshima behind him and this
is what Hiroshima looks like now it
wasn't exactly the end of the world for
the further Hiroshima but I don't
certainly want to downplay that tragedy
but there's been a tendency to do
basically is to simply to to exaggerate
the impact of even nuclear weapons and
in that sense not that thousands of them
going across the North Pole wouldn't be
a massive catastrophe but the impact of
much smaller explosions has been
substantially exaggerated for example
Robert Muller was asked I mean
open Hamer was asked in a Charlie after
World War two there's there it would
have had four men smuggled in atomic
bombs and he said with one atomic bombs
smuggle them they could blow up New York
well they could do a lot of damage
nuclear terrorism in other words it's
not something that has only recently
been discussed that small numbers of
people setting went off but if they were
able to set off a Hiroshima bomb on the
ground which is presumably what they
would do in New York they would not
destroyed New York they would destroy
one percent of New York now what if it's
you know which were a lot of people are
and they're a lot of people in new york
towers he'd be horrible but there's a
difference between one percent and one
hundred percent and so that's the kind
of thing i'm someone concerned about
just recently nature last year
scientific magazine in britain talked
about even a fizzle van heu device could
take out most of an manhattan well a
fizzle of a heu device set off in the
middle of Central Park would not destroy
any of the buildings on the periphery in
other words this is this kind of
apocalyptic exaggeration it's something
that bothers me it doesn't again it's
not that they aren't horrible weapons
it's just that this kind of flip idea
that one goes off the whole world ends
is basically not there it's not is not
wise it seems to me and it doesn't help
with policymaking george tenet that
we're talking now about the former
director of the Central Intelligence
Agency says if al-qaeda match is set up
a mushroom cloud they would make history
no question about that such an event
would put al Qaeda on a par with the
superpowers the United States has tens
of thousands of nuclear weapons that's
not quite the same part seems to me and
make good bin Laden's threat to destroy
our economy one bomb would destroy the
economy of the United States one bomb
would be really really bad it would have
a very significant impact I've already
given you some numbers about it but it
the idea that would they would that if a
bomb goes off in you know Peoria
Illinois that everybody stops farming
businesses stop working if anything of
course if 911 is any example would tend
to bring people together to recover as
fast as possible and to keep the economy
going so again this kind of societal
exaggeration okay related to that
is it seems me nuclear weapons have been
a very little historical consequence
they've not been necessary to prevent
World War 3 or a major conflict in
Europe there is a famous thing knows the
Churchill what I call the church of
counterfactual that this curious period
paradox and a simply supreme irony
whereby nuclear weapons vastly spread
the error mortal danger with the
potential result that safety will become
a sturdy child to terror and survival
the twin brother of annihilation or put
in somewhat more prosaic phrases it
basically are the archers whole argument
is basically that essentially people
were so stupid incompetent moronic that
the only thing keeping them from getting
into World War 3 was the fact that they
had to think about mushroom clouds
that's essentially it seems to me what
he's saying and you might talk John
goddess will be here next week when he
been arguing about this issue for about
30 years so he'll have a different
perspective on it I think but anyway the
basic idea it seems to me just nonsense
that did that if there were not nuclear
weapons a big war would look very much
like World War World War 2 the countries
that were running the world since World
War two we're the same countries that
suffered considerable cost in World War
two and they didn't want to do that
again they certainly didn't want to do
it again with nuclear weapons as well
but it was already the case that they
were strongly not interested in getting
into a war with each other they didn't
need mushroom clouds to realize that
I've used the argument that the nuclear
weapons are like putting a straitjacket
on a Quaker it is true it reduces
likelihood to go on a rampage of murder
but it's a rather unnecessary extra
insurance the other aspect of this is
what the what I seemed to me that the
main reason for the what's happened
since world war two and the cold war
which was Soviet ideology and although
the Soviet Union was aggressive in the
sense that they wanted to change the
world in their direction and he wanted
foment revolution and encouraged
revolutionaries and encourage wars of
national liberation fact they saw call
that saw that as their sacred duty as
crucial ones put it they didn't they
never ever have had the idea of doing
that with Hitlerian type of dress
and because that would blow everything
out of the water probably it's just too
dangerous so they're tat they have
tactics in their violent they're using
revolution and so forth but they never
had the idea of using of starting a
direct war whether conventional or not
so therefore the main anti status quo
force during the Cold War it seems to me
was definitely one to change the status
quo no question about that but they were
not they were not hit luring they didn't
they never saw that as part of their as
part of their a plan of attack this
Robert Jervis has pointed out in an
article recently the Soviet archives
have yet to reveal any serious plants or
unprovoked aggression against Western
Europe not to mention a first strike
against the United States there just
never was any idea that that was a good
idea and so it's not the weapons that
cause Wars its ideas that cause Wars and
their idea was we don't want to do that
at all with or without nuclear weapons
the in addition the weapons have seen to
be pretty weapons that do exist to prove
them to be pretty useless and a very
substantial waste of money and of
scientific and technical talent there
never been militarily compelling reasons
to use them the incidence of this is
colin powell was asked by the then
Secretary of Defense Dick Cheney to look
into you know what are the possibilities
about nuclear weapons in the Gulf War in
1991 as you can see they looked into it
he said you know it doesn't make any
sense if you need to knock out the enemy
tanks you can do it just as well or even
better with nuclear weapon Eric weapons
and that you don't need nuclear weapons
to do it and that's generally been what
happened they looked at during the
Korean War was their way you could use
them and mostly it wasn't worth it they
mean they just weren't valuable they
weren't they weren't useful from a
strictly military standpoint so it's not
clear that they've really anybody's
really benefited from having them now
what Albert Einstein very famously said
they bomb has changed everything except
our way of thinking and it seems to me
me had it upside down backwards that has
changed nothing except our way of
thinking so and I'd be glad to go into
this in more detail but I want to try to
finish up here so you can
so we have some discussion that
basically what happened was that after
the the Cold War during the Cold War the
weapons did have a major impact but that
was basically intellectual they they had
a tremendous influence on agonies and
obsessions and they inspired a lot of
desperate rhetoric extravagant
theorizing wasteful expenditure and
frenetic diplomatic posturing I don't
think they changed history that is say
they didn't deter a world war they
weren't useful and to in you know Berlin
crises or any other Vietnam or anyplace
else or for the Soviets in Afghanistan
or the British in the Falklands but but
they did inspire what Robert Johnson is
called nuclear metaphysics one of my
favorite statements about this is dwight
eisenhower we are piling up our mess
because we don't know do what else to do
to provide for our security really
pathetic we're building these things we
don't even know why we're building them
and we don't know you have any other
ideas anyway it led to this idea what
Robert Johnson calls nuclear metaphysics
elaborate decades worth decades and
decades worth of theorizing about how
many ICBMs could balance on the head of
an mi how many mir vs could it balanced
on the head of an ICBM and a whole bunch
of extravagant theorizing about reentry
vehicles about multiple re-entry
vehicles but multiple independently
really targetable re-entry vehicles and
a bunch of other things like fo BS and
lick'em one of my favorite things and
flexible response and so forth and how
you could arrange things to reduce the
danger of nuclear war basically it seems
to me there was never really any serious
possibility of it and the doctrine of
mutual assured destruction was
profoundly misguided in the sense that
there was nothing to deter there was no
enemy that was remotely interested in
getting any kind of War nuclear or not
there were problems there were problems
like vietnam and korean things but there
were not the idea of a direct attack
okay let me talk now about the second
issue which i think some of the things i
already said well sort of you know
you know that follows from that if
nuclear weapons haven't been very
important than the proliferation of them
is probably not all that important
anyway either this is extremely
unconventional everybody assumes it's a
bad thing and I'm inclined to think you
know unbalanced it's a good thing that
doesn't happen but nonetheless I'm not
going to get very alarmed about it to
begin with the proliferation of nuclear
weapons when the power slower than
predicted because the weapons do not
generally convey much advantage to their
possessor something of a basically
already said so you look at it and say
how much does it cost to build those
weapons what good are they the answer
comes Zach well actually nothing in
large number of countries have gone
through that calculus a John Kennedy on
the other hand is famous for this
statement personally I'm haunted by the
feeling that by the 1970s there's gonna
be 10 or 15 nuclear powers or 25 or some
number like that and he kept he gets
spouting that throughout and during that
time basically nobody nothing has
happened or very little has happened
this this is the list that he was given
a list by the CIA about potential
nuclear countries and these are that
this is the list you know all those
countries like Canada and Belgium and
Netherlands in Norway in Switzerland
they all were technically capable
getting nuclear weapons and I did I did
an article in 1967 is published in Orbis
called Canada's and non-nuclear power I
thought it'd be understand look at a
country that could have become a nuclear
country and didn't do so in Canada was
it and then i looked at the
disincentives for canada to get nuclear
weapons very technologically
sophisticated country and basically it
seemed to me that they were relevant to
a large number of countries on this list
besides canada not all of them at some
the only countries on the list actually
that ever got around getting nuclear
weapons is not 10 or 15 but three on
this list Canada Israel and India and
took india until to the end of the
century nonetheless what you get is
people like Mohamed ElBaradei saying
that we're now reaching a tipping point
where I think Kennedy's prediction is
very much alive and it's going to happen
we're going to have 20 or 30 countries
with nuclear weapons if we don't stop it
and if that means is the beginning of
the end of civilization so the mere fact
that Kennedy's prediction has been wrong
for 50 years didn't cause him any kind
of anguish instead he said now it's
really happening and so he got a lot of
things about Cascades tipping points
avalanche's waves change dominoes
epidemics and points of no return in
terms of nuclear weapons proliferation
despite the fact that the proliferation
has been extraordinarily slow for good
reason and the good reason is this I've
already alluded to it but the basic
thing is that the difficulties of
producing a me by a country are just
incredibly high and so but what has
happened as people haven't looked at
these countries and said you know if you
do that you have to do this that you
ever thing it's not you know it's pretty
well known what you need to do and its
really expensive and difficult and
countries that have tried to get them
like Libya and found that very much
themselves if I may quote Mohamed
ElBaradei as you may recall Libya gave
up its nuclear weapons program in 2003
or so I've been working on them for off
and on for 10 or 15 or 20 years
ElBaradei who is the United Nations
inspector came there and he was allowed
access to their nuclear weapons program
he found that they'd bought billions of
dollars worth of stuff and it was still
in the packing boxes they hadn't been
able to take it out to figure out to put
tab a into slot B or D put slotted to be
into Tab A or whatever and but
nevertheless ElBaradei said this I Libya
was in the preparatory stages of
developing a capability to move it to
acquire nuclear weapons let us say it
was preparing to develop a capability to
move my question is how is that
different being sound asleep you know
certainly wakes up in the morning saying
okay I'm preparing to develop a
capability to move and it just I mean it
but what happens is that it's very
difficult he didn't have a scientific
talent the money was running out
gradually he realized there wasn't any
payoff in in any way and he basically
gave up and a lot of countries have gone
through that calculation calculation
some of them very early stages just give
no Sweden looked into it he cited wasn't
worth the candle even though obviously
could have spent the money and done it
if they wanted to and many many other
countries around Canada's lists various
basic God didn't get very far on it now
there's also the concern of this gets
very much into Frank Gavin's material
john kennedy talking about the Chinese
because we're worried about rogue states
well as Frank has pointed out the
quintessential rogue state of all time
was communist China 1964 when they got
nuclear weapons Kennedy was
extraordinarily concerned about it is he
said that a Chinese nuclear test is
likely to be historically the most
significant and worst event of the
1960's once again as director of the
Central Intelligence Agency John McCone
said unless the Chinese threat is met by
much strengthen Western alliance nuclear
war is almost inevitable once they get
the bomb well it turned out that
probably going back to Kennedy statement
the most significant and worst event of
the 1960s was Kennedy's decision to
escalate in Vietnam which was largely
concerned about the increasing Chinese
threat in that area as part of the main
motivation for getting into Vietnam both
quite him and by Johnson but anyway he's
in there in the mix and what has
happened when trying to got the bomb
well I mentioned his Robert Johnson
before it said talk about nuclear
metaphysics and only recently did I
discover partly because of Frank's
writings on this in fact was that he was
in the State Department in 1964 when
these decisions are necessary was being
around and he was asked to do a briefing
or a paper on it and he looked in and he
said well they get nuclear weapons won't
make much difference you know we don't
have to change our policy very much
we'll keep an eye on him obviously
things change but it's not that big a
deal and he was totally right for once a
voice of reason even in the State
Department even in Washington my god
radical and so what what is China done
with the nuclear weapons well nothing
it's built far fewer than it could have
had wanted to it has not used them
particularly for threats or anything
and most people probably don't even know
China has nuclear weapons furthermore if
people looked at China as an impressive
country very few of them are going to
say it has nuclear weapons therefore
it's impressive they're going to say wow
look at that economy or wow they'd
really put on a really terrific Olympics
no one says they we have to pay
attention to because because they have
nuclear weapons anymore the people like
French food because we have to eat this
stuff because they have nuclear weapons
you know it's just doesn't go or the
British so basically that it hasn't they
haven't used it for prestige
particularly they haven't used them at
all and they don't have very many of
them by considering but they could have
they wanted to so in it despite the fact
that they seem to be very roguish and
we're fairly irresponsible in some of
the rhetoric plus lead attack India a
couple years earlier at cetera they're
very much supporting words of national
liberation the weapons were just SAT the
SAT there and presumably to deter a
country that might want to attack that
had been constantly threatening them for
example the United States of America so
if they had any function at all of us to
deter wasn't necessary i don't think but
that's about it so it hasn't been the
end of the world china is wasted in my
view a lot of time money and scientific
talent on it but it hasn't hasn't really
it has not in any remote sounds
demonstrated the macone was right that
that the nuclear war is almost
inevitable okay so as this sort of
suggests a nuclear proliferation it says
well I basically don't think it's
terribly desirable it's unlikely to
accelerate or prove to be a major danger
the and also efforts to keep rogue
states from obtaining them have been
substantially counterproductive and have
caused far more deaths have been
inflicted by all nuclear or even all
weapons of mass destruction attacks in
history a particular case is in Iraq a
sanctions during the 1990s according
commit some calculation at least led to
hundreds of thousands of deaths in Iraq
there's a lot to speed about the numbers
there's not very much dispute about the
proliferation war against Iraq in 2003
it has led to the deaths of easily a
hundred thousand people in Iraq and the
idea and it was mainly a war to stop
Saddam Hussein from getting
or getting rid of the weapons he may
have had which could be labeled weapons
of mass destruction and it seems me
basically the essentially what has
happened is that a hundred thousand is
about the number of people who died at
Hiroshima and Nagasaki combined maybe a
little bit higher than that and that's
about the number of people who died
because of the anti proliferation war
against Iraq in this century and so
consequently the alternative would have
been to let him sit there and if he
develops nuclear weapons that would be
unfortunate and would not be very
pleasant but basically what you do is
work out an alliance of convenience to
keep him contained and deterred since he
had an army which he didn't trust for
example he would not allow the army into
Baghdad with heavy equipment for fear
would be used against him and since he
was careful about issuing too many
bullets to his army it was not exactly
the case if he's going to conquer the
Middle East without army or that if he
even ordered them to use some of these
weapons they'd actually carry it out but
my point is that the obsession with him
getting nuclear weapons has now cost a
hundred thousand lives and the obsession
with Iraq with Iran and and with the
Korea similarly Graham Allison in his
book nuclear terrorism is it argues that
nuclear proliferation to countries like
North Korea Iran should be the supreme
priority my thinking is rather that
there's nothing wrong with making
non-proliferation a high priority but it
should be topped with a somewhat higher
one avoiding policies that can lead to
the deaths of tens or hundreds of
thousands of people under the obsessive
sway of worst-case scenario fantasies
like if North Korea gets the bomb
they're going to do all kinds of funny
things with it or they're going to cause
South Korea and Japan to get nuclear
weapons which Ellison predicted in 9
2004 and said in fact North Korea would
have enough to make 70 or 90 nuclear
weapons by the end of the century 2009
and and he also basically says if they
get in that book if they do get nuclear
weapons which is written before they got
their first explosion did the first test
they would
that they should start a war against
them unfortunately there's a lot of
South Koreans who live very close to
north korea in particular in the city of
seoul and ellison suggested that we
would you first you do you evacuate soul
which now has the worst traffic jams now
in on the planet practically and then
you then you attack North Korea and he
also talks about it might lead to 10 it
might lead to 80 thousand deaths so
that's what I mean you having North
Korea and not have a nuclear weapon it's
just fine with me if diplomacy or
bribery or something can keep them from
doing so terrific if it making nice to
them stoking your egos can do so fine
fine fine it's okay with me but starting
wars against them but you're going to
kill tens of thousands of Koreans north
and south in order to stop your
obsession you're in the service of that
kind of worst-case scenario obsession of
what they might do with the weapons
strikes me as being just distinctly
invalid okay finally the question about
nuclear terrorism the argument in my
view is that the likelihood that
terrorists will get nuclear weapons is
extremely low quite possibly go on to
discuss this a little bit more but let
me give you a that's what vanishing
small looks like the people have been
predicting for a long time the nuclear
terrorists would come about a theater
Taylor was a physicist a guy named John
McPhee wrote a book about him in the
early 1970s and Taylor said the problem
is the media its comparative easy to
steal nuclear material and step-by-step
to make it into a bomb to fabricate a
crude nuclear weapon is simple all you
need is some plutonium oxide powder some
high explosives and then run down to the
hardware store and pick up a few things
you know nuts and bolts stick it
together and he said it's our it's
already too late to prevent the making
of a few bombs by sub-national groups
terrorist groups or criminal groups or
whatever and in a nut or he also says it
another 10 or 15 years it'll be too late
that is say bye 1985 we're still waiting
Graham Allison in 1995 said in the
absence of the German program
we have every reason to anticipate new
acts of nuclear terrorism against
nuclear contar gates before this decade
is out that is say the decade of the
1990s his record and prediction
continues we were into this next pattern
with his 2004 book in which he said it's
my considered judgment that in the
current path a nuclear terrorist attack
on America in the decade ahead is more
likely than not there's a lot of people
lots of people agree with that and
obviously we're getting to 2014 and
closing in on it on the decade but he's
got a few more years to to work it out
this view is very influential John
Negroponte another intelligence guy
later promoted there's a high
probability that within two years al
Qaeda will attempt an attack using a
nuclear or other weapon of mass
destruction he said this in 2003 later
he is pointed head of intelligence
little things like being making
boneheaded statements like that doesn't
seem to be didn't seem to slow down his
career and no one even remembers often
when they do so George Tenet my favorite
CIA director was saying in 2003 that bin
Laden has a sophisticated biological
weapons capability as far as they know
that's based on nothing we know
obviously quite a few years from that
you may notice that no terrorist has
used a biological weapon no terrorist
has even used including in Iraq much on
the way even of chemical weapons and
certainly they haven't done anything in
terms of nuclear explosions so we've had
this kind of what I think is you know
massive exaggeration Walter lacquered
wanted some one of the top gurus of
terrorism said in 1996 it's on terrorist
groups will almost certainly use weapons
of mass destruction in the foreseeable
future 1996 2010 I think we've already
done the foreseeable future doesn't look
too good for that prediction okay what
I'd like to do is talk about there's one
way of getting the bomb which Ellison
and just about everybody else thinks is
the most likely but let me talk about
two other ways that it Paris might get a
bomb one is it someone to give them
about a rogue state Iran gets nuclear
weapons gives to Hezbollah or whatever
most analysts
and there are polls on this to think
that that's fairly unlikely they don't
see that as most likely route the
argument is that bombs can be traced or
there's a there's a strong possibility
they can be traced is the thing known as
nuclear met nuclear forensics such that
if you get the bomb before it's exploded
or if it is exploded afterwards you can
tell where the uranium or plutonium came
from because they have signatures by
countries and we can't guarantee by any
means that won't be found out so if you
give a weapon to a terrorist and he sets
it off there may have a home address
because I know where the bomb originally
came from in addition it's extremely
unlikely most people think that anybody
would trust a terrorist with a precious
bomb one of the possibilities or anybody
they can completely control because one
of the possibilities is that the bomb
will actually go off in the country that
gave the bomb away so there's various
reasons by that there's also the problem
of stings that people are constantly
coming around trying to buy bombs and
and so therefore they do start to make
nice to somebody who's talking about
that there's a danger that the you'll be
found out even before the bomb is
transferred the second technique would
be by stealing a bomb that you find a
disgruntled Russian physicist which is
the usual pattern or a or a underpaid
guy in a in a guarding buttons and you
basically steal a bomb which some
presuming some sort of insider
complicity that's all so that seems to
be this is this is the loose nukes
argument which is very popular about ten
years ago and has been declining it
meaning because no one has ever been
able to find any loose nukes or a hero
the trail of them stealing a bomb the
problem there is that the bombs all come
with safety attachments which are
designed if tampered with to blow up the
bomb with a conventional explosion and
there's multiple things like that and
there's an even simpler techniques the
Pakistanis for example reportedly keep
their bombs and in pieces so there's
peace a is in one secure site and peace
be is another secure site you have to
get both pieces figure out
put them together get past the locks and
then be able to set them off most
weapons also require constant
maintenance and so you have to know how
to do that not very many people know how
to set them off the people who design
them don't know how to defeat the safety
doll locks and the people have
maintained them don't have the foggiest
idea how to set them off so you have to
steal exactly the right people along
with the bomb so a possibility obviously
the bottoms do exist but it's very
tricky one indeed there's also one third
thing which almost everybody disagrees
it thinks is extremely unlikely which
would be make a bomb from from scratch
to make a bomb there's two things you
have to do essentially one is to get the
fissile material which is the highly
enriched uranium or the plutonium the
main makings of the bomb then you have
to make manufacture seconds to
manufacture the bomb itself with a
fissile material most people argue that
that including people are most alarmed
about nuclear terrorism that'd be very
very very difficult for a sub state
group to make the weapons grade uranium
or the plutonium it's very takes a big
industrial capacity so therefore they
don't think a terrorist could do that
the most likely path is the one that
most people talk about which is making a
bomb with purloined fissile material you
steal or bi or finagle the fissile
material from a state that has it Russia
Pakistan whoever then you take the
fissile material to a machine shop and
you make it into a bomb and so that's
that that's the scenario i'd like to
deal with we can certainly deal with the
other ones as well as you want more
later ok what I did was I mean dealing
with is it there's a very good book some
of you may have read by a guy named
William languages was called atomic
bizarre be azz are-- and in it he's got
one he's a writes for The Atlantic in
particular he's got one chapter about
making a nuclear bomb and the attack he
took struck me as being really
interesting he basically is okay you're
a terrorist what he
have to do well you have to do this and
you have to do this and you have to do
this and have to do this it's not
looking at you have to look at the whole
whole chain of things anyway I reviewed
the book for the bulletin of Atomic
Scientists and talk about that and so
forth and then when I started working on
atomic accession I basically took the
review and expanded it from 400 words to
know 20,000 or something like that using
languages stuff plus a lot of other
stuff as well of course and so what I've
done is try to put together a narrative
which I'd like to give you now and very
quick outline about what you have to do
if you're a terrorist you want to make a
bomb with stolen pasado material and
what I've done is sort of bulleted the
steps so they're about 20 of them I'm
not about their exactly 20 of them I
could actually have had more and split
them apart but you know 20 seemed to be
a nice number so I fell in love with it
and that's what we got the desert if
three aspects one is getting the fissile
material and getting into where you can
use it the second is actually making the
bomb and the third is delivering the
bomb and setting it off so those are the
three sequences and I not going to talk
about these in complete detail because
there's much time but do I certainly be
glad to deal with it more later but what
you have to do if your terrorist is go
to some place that has in adequately
secured source of uranium I think
enriched uranium is heu highly enriched
uranium is presumably the preferred
technique because it's much easier to
work with than plutonium and we're
assuming in all this the terrorists are
willing to cut corners take risks and
even lose lives in order to get their
thing done knows they're trying to do it
on as cheap as possible okay you have to
go to some place which has it for
example a little village some place in
Kazakh in in in in part of Russia
someplace and formally could have been
Kazakhstan but and so you walk in there
you go down to the corner bar and say
anybody here have any ID enriched
uranium to sell what you have to do is
find someone who can lead you to the
material and so the one of the major
problems in all this is the process of
getting insiders corrupting them
a disgruntled Russian physicist for
example in getting them so that they
will help you and be completely reliable
throughout now there presumably if you
if you're a Muslim extremists for
example al-qaeda the average Russian
physicist is not a just is not a Muslim
fanatic but they might be interested in
money so what you have to do is find
these guys and you have to and probably
finding these guys means you have to pay
people in between the gun to connect you
middlemen and each of them has to be
paid off they're all being they're all
criminals now they're very corrupted and
they may keep raising the price the more
they know the more you're dependent on
them the more they may raise the price
at any rate you go in and you find these
guys supposedly you don't raise any
suspicions yeah we always have Muslim
extremists around here looking for
plutonium and and the and the insight in
ciders have to be completely loyal
throughout now let me just raise two
problems with this and there's sort of
summarizing some of these points here
one is that the god is disgruntled
Russian physicist and he's willing saves
willing to do it okay the money's good
you know he hasn't been able to buy a
BMW at all he's living on very bad
salary and nobody pays give them any
respect so what the hell he's going to
go for it and so he's willing to be
bought he's willing to be corrupted and
he knows where the uranium is ok well
there's a couple of thought thought
patterns it might go through his mind
over the period of time which he's
thinking about this one is as follows if
I if I steal this uranium and give it to
these guys and by the way is probably
take more than one person to do this but
anyway if I do this eventually they're
going to see maybe very soon they're
going to see that the uranium is missing
now how many people know have access to
that uranium not many who's one of them
me so if I'm driving around in a new you
know BMW on my salary I'm going to raise
a certain amount of suspicion eventually
in other words they're going to figure
it out Evite's you know try to flee the
country that will make it even more so
you know it is suspicious and so so what
he's going to say is this is not a
really good idea maybe I should go to
the authorities
and say well of course I was just
stringing them along I never had any
idea of doing this I'm a loyal rush on
etc etc but in the back of his mind he
realized there's something worse than
being a disgruntled Russian physicist
that's being a dead disgruntled Russian
physicist and so consequently it becomes
a sting effectively or another
possibility is that he does it and he's
just incompetent or or it becomes it's a
scam he does it he takes the money and
gives you the stuff that's useless lots
of scams around okay anyway that's one
scenario that he basically cooperates in
some way or the other but it becomes a
sting then the other thing he's going to
think about is that ok I do the thing
and I get the stuff and I'm really slick
about it I get it out and I give it to
them and now they're going to take the
money they can take the stuff away I've
not got months to think about this and I
want to think about it from their
standpoint I know who they are I know
roughly where they're going after the
uranium is Miss found missing there'd be
a lot of questions asked they have to
assume that I will be asked about this
and they have to assume that under the
right kind of duress I might give
information so what's their best idea
namely kill me and so that again
concentrates the mind being a dead
Russian physicist by either standard is
not exactly ideal it's better be just
plain disgruntled anyway the you can see
the complexity of this you got a bunch
of people you have to corrupt you have
to keep them completely loyal they
wouldn't be necessarily part of the
Muslim extremist movement and they have
to know it'd be really competent to they
have to know what they're doing and not
some bozos drunk for three quarters of
the time okay anyway you do it then you
try to get it out you have to get it
over an international border which what
some of these other things are talking
about and there you probably also have
to trust smugglers now after the HEU is
found missing and enough of it missing
to make a bomb or more than one bomb it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be very largely
about a hundred pounds but uranium is
extremely heavy heavier than lead so the
package would not be very big but you
have to smuggle it out it's not if it's
rhenium it won't be all that radioactive
either so the wood hard to detect but
anyway you have to get it out you
probably want to you there's a lot of
smuggling roads
and you wanna use smugglers probably
help you but once uranium is gone
there's going to be one heck of a rents
a reward for information that can lead
to the apprehension of the people who
stole the uranium I mean you as a
terrorist group may have lots of money
but you're not nearly as rich as all the
countries in the world they have really
deep pockets so therefore the smuggler
who says these guys are to look kind of
strange they got this one rather small
but extremely heavy package and they
start putting things together and they
may not want to be part of a plot it
kills 10,000 or 50,000 people either
maybe they're just smuggling drugs or
whatever they're not you know how to
kill people necessarily in mass and so
consequently you can have that kind of
thing happening and so these people also
have to be trusted they must not get
suspicious okay the second issue is has
to do with basically making the bomb and
let me deal with some of the problems in
there and these are you know dealing
with it in various ways but what you
have to do then is set up a machine shop
someplace languish o really likes
Istanbul so he decides he likes to think
about Istanbul so he decides he would
put the machine shop in Istanbul and so
you set up this machine shops and you
get a bunch of physicists from you know
Pakistan you or something going and
coming in the slum and nobody gets
suspicious you bring in a lot of
expensive equipment in this windowless
machine shop and people go in and out
all the time they're working in there no
one gets suspicious the locals don't get
suspicious the police don't get
suspicious the local criminal gangs
don't get suspicious anyway you're
working along even if you're somewhat
isolated you know you can't be
completely isolated probably and so
something some there's some danger it
also means that the physicists you put
into this position who must be really
loyal working for months or years on
this project must never spill anything
to anybody that they must their wives or
whoever they left back at Pakistan you
must say you know he's always going on
vacations we never know where he went
that's just you know what I think about
physicists by the way the Pakistanis
keep very close watch on on their
scientific talent both active and
retired
so there be that problem after being
completely loyal they can't spill the
beans the two prostitutes or somebody
across a bar or people they bump into or
anything or any suspicions and no one
must be figure it out then what you have
is also the difficulty of actually
making the bomb it's commonly argued
sometimes argued that it's child's play
once you have the uranium but this is a
statement from Stephen younger rather
long I'm afraid but you get the gist of
it pretty quickly now he was the head of
weapons development of Los Alamos before
retiring and as you can see this is long
screed I could have even more if you
want but basically saying it's really
hard to do and another book of my recent
book called the bomb he basically says
it's it's basically far-fetched to think
that any sub-state group even if they
have the uranium could actually pull
this off there aren't there aren't
blueprints there aren't plans readily
available and it takes a lot a huge
amount of talent okay then finally
basically you have to get it to a BF dad
to set it off you have to get it to the
country that you want to set it off
which invariably in these scenarios is
the United States and the target almost
invariably is Times Square and then you
set it off you have to be able to have
people in the country who are not simply
thugs which were most of the people of
911 were but they have to be
technologically pretty sophisticated you
have to move this thing which now is a
bomb or as a device would weigh about a
ton and they have to receive it it comes
through UPS does it is that how you get
there with a return address or your hire
an airplane you have to trust more
people etc then they get it to the place
where it is they try to set it off
hoping fervently that it won't prove to
be a dud it's not been tested it's
traveled three four five seven thousand
miles it weighs a ton as you've done by
you guys in a sweaty machine shop and
the storms of Istanbul it's ever anyway
don't you get the idea that basically
it's it's extraordinary difficult task
it's a and also the notion that al-qaeda
has a capacity of desire to attain
nuclear weapon strikes me as being much
inflated now there's various evidence of
some interest perhaps
for example the there was a guy who said
that they tried the original buying some
uranium back when they're in Sudan in
1994 guy named Votto who defected after
stealing 110 thousand dollars from
al-qaeda and this story has been
contradicted by others and so ever maybe
it's true maybe they had some interest
in it turned out the material that they
supposedly were interested in was was it
wasn't any good anyway so there's some
interest here and there they were there
just before nine eleven there were
records now of conversations they had
with some Pakistani scientists who are
working in Afghanistan who had worked on
the bomb program and they SAT around and
they had basically academic discussions
included the sama bin Laden and they
talked about chemical and biological
nuclear weapons Graham Allison and his
book says that American intelligence
thinks that the scientists gave the gave
the al-qaeda the blueprints for how to
make a bomb that would be really
impressive because these guys didn't
know how to make a bomb they worked on
the program but they were the Pakistani
nuclear program but the program they
worked on was the was on making the
fissile material not on actually
building the bomb so they knew the basic
physics of course of it but they and
they do parent lee drew some rough
sketches but that's it that's sort of
limited then there's also the evidence
in afghanistan when the united states
came in no evidence of any real work on
this there's some there's a 25 page
handwritten document called super bomb
that has something about how to make a
bomb but a lot of it's just plain wrong
and there's a few other indications here
and there it's also the case that the
wall street journal is able to get a
computer that al-qaeda had used and the
budgets were on there and they did have
a budget for weapons of mass destruction
which apparently is devoted entirely
almost entirely to chemical weapons but
the budget was about two or three
thousand dollars not exactly a rampant
thing then there's also a guy named
hamid mir who's been there's other
evidence during if you want to talk
about a bit it tends to be this kind of
fragmentary stuff but shortly before I
Taft ER 911 hamid mir a pakistani
journalist was invited into the
interview bin laden and apparently
though
and these are the statements they gave
that we have nuclear weapons we have
chemical weapons and we'll use them as a
deterrent etc and Zawahiri said you all
you have to do is go to Soviet Union you
show up with your ID and a couple of
credit cards and you can pick up and
pick them up in Tashkent or Moscow or
whatever this was just a few days like
two days before they're about to flee
the country and it seems pretty obvious
that they shouldn't be taken and face
value particularly since there's no
corroborating evidence they were
obviously Bluffs to try to scare the
Americans away from attacking and see
then I think should be taken in that
light okay so at any rate my conclusion
is this and whatever their impact on
activists rhetoric strategic theorizing
defense budgets and political posturing
nuclear weapons have had best quite
limited impact on history have been a
substantial waste of time money and
effort and scientific talent have not
been appealing to most states that do
not have them are out of reach for
terrorists and unlikely to shape much of
our future so let me end on that
optimistic note I know you're supposed
to be pessimistic around here but I
thought I'd give it a different role
thank
kind of disappointed at you're going to
be controversial there's something kind
of it's easy I'm sure there's lots of
questions in the audience if could line
up behind there where the microphone is
and a fire away whatever questions you
might have I sort of want to start out
with one you've obviously given this
presentation and the one on the earlier
book I'm interested in one sort of you
kind of said you were surprised that
people didn't disagree more i was
wondering with this latest book what was
sort of the angriest response you ever
got or what was sort of what was the
tenor response isn't too is there anyone
ever in a position of policy who may
have heard you talk about this it said I
kind of agree with you but I lose my job
all right I can't really well no one to
go quite that far I did say when I did
overblown I explained to somebody at
americol I think it's International
Studies Association conference you know
it's what my perspective on this that
thread have been massively exaggerated
and so forth and he and he's one of guys
he's written a lot about terrorism very
smart guy he said well you know I
basically agree with you but you just
can't say that I did it anyway and
that's why a little bit worried about
being lynched for example but I thought
people would say well you don't care
about 911 you don't care about a living
people and so forth and you don't have
any sense of concern about that and that
basically hasn't happened the I've been
attacked by michael chertoff that's
pretty good in an op-ed and actually
fits did some of this discussion
incidentally another issue about nuclear
weapons he did a book get an article in
the op-ed in the Philadelphia Inquirer
this is when he was Secretary of
Homeland Security and he says Mueller's
overblown he obviously haven't read the
book but he caught you mentioned it and
he said that the probability of being
killed by terrorists is very small but
what if they get nuclear weapons well I
you know talk about that in the book and
obviously
much more in the current book but what
he was doing with that was justifying
the whole homeland security budget by
the nuclear weapon threat now I've
agreed that you know nuclear weapons are
the only way probably you can get to the
point where the expenditure on Homeland
Security makes sense on the other hand
if that's the case mostly what you want
to do is deal with nuclear weapons in
some respects actually Greymon else
Graham Allison and I agree and and I you
know I said some some of nasty things
maybe or at least certainly disagreeing
hope they were nasty but certainly
disagreeing things about Allison's work
but he's been at the forefront of
locking up nukes and locking up fissile
material around the country and I think
that's generally a good thing even
though obviously I'm not remotely as
alarmed about the situation is him but
it goes back to stuff I talked out at
the beginning in my opinion when you got
something which is an acceptable risk
you don't really want to spend a lot of
money on it unless it's cheap in other
words it's something bitches and so with
the nuclear weapons which you got it
seems to me is something that could be
really bad but in my opinion when you
multiply by the probability it's not
that big a deal and so therefore
spending lots of money to make that risk
even lower doesn't make sense you should
spend it on cancer or something but
small amounts of money to make it even
lower that's fine so that I mean like
bathtubs you know if there's some cheap
way you could you could reduce the
number of people drowning in bathtubs
from 300 to 150 per year I mean that's
you know they're on it's not a very big
risk not very many people died rounding
a bathtub so if you could reduce that
with very inexpensive things like
putting a label on bathtubs playing
don't drown you know that would be okay
you know because even though the risk is
very small the amount you're spending to
make the reduce the risk even lower is
also small so small expenditures are
there but spending huge amounts of money
like getting rid of all bathtubs for
example to save those 300 lights for a
year would seem to be crazy and
expensive and all kinds of other
problems so in the case of nuclear
weapons the the efforts to reduce though
I think obviously the likelihood of a
terrorist getting nuclear weapons is
extremely small on the other hand the
efforts to make this even lower are not
very expensive they are for example
doing things like making sure that
Pakistan's nuclear weapons all have good
sophisticated lock systems on them so
that's great and and I think you want to
do that anyway because of other problems
and it's also it kept making sure you
know where fissile material is I mean
that's just like bookkeeping I mean it
takes work you have people going around
bureaucrats and making sure that they
catalog every piece of fissile material
so that if something goes missing they
know they know that right away and they
can also keep it so that doesn't go
missing me put under more locks that's
not expensive stuff and that's what else
in mostly wants to do and basically even
though obviously I'm not nearly as
alarmed as he is it does seem to be a
worthwhile expenditure mainly because
it's so cheap so there's a bit of
agreement there in them I want to thank
you for your perspective it's really
nice to have a balance to this
discussion on nuclear the nuclear threat
my Terrace I'm just um oh I'm just
wondering if you think that there is any
intent in this exaggeration any kind of
what intent in this exaggeration and
what is it what do you think the motive
is bye-bye academics and officials to
come and you know tell us that new New
York will be bombed in 10 to 20 years
like Robert glue Chi yeah well overblown
deals with that a lot the issue about
some fear mongering essentially to try
to get a policy across I don't think
very many people is it at all are being
are very cynical I think they did it I
certainly do not want to suggest in any
way that Graham Allison for example is
insincere I mean he certainly believes
all that he's very alarming concern I
disagree with him but I certainly did
not consider him to be
you know purposely lying or exaggerating
exaggerating but there does to be there
does there is sort of a tendency to do
it naturally so that if you are working
the Department of Homeland Security on
these issues you don't want to say
things which essentially saying my
budget is too big now that doesn't mean
you're not alarmed about problem you're
obviously a social you have a social
responsibility to carry out your task
and so forth but there isn't much
incentive to say we're spending too much
money on Homeland Security if you're a
politician you're afraid of losing votes
and if I think if they opponents people
that I'm soft on terrorism as one time
politicians worry about being called
soft on communism I'm going to lose
votes so therefore you know I better
play to these fears and exacerbate them
and the media you know having story that
says nukes are not a big deal you know
sells about three newspapers Newton
finding things about you know the saying
things that are that are the hysterical
or not let me give you an example did
there's this new movie which I haven't
seen yet but I've seen an excerpt from
it and read about it called getting
towards zero or something something
toward zero getting rid nuclear weapons
it's made by the same to have made
inconvenient truth and they at one point
they have Joseph Surrency own lose a
friend of mine in Washington talking
about at one point there was a bogus the
Russians thought the United States had
launched a nuclear weapon at them and
Yeltsin the president at the time was
activated and and so they were just all
ages push the button and they're going
to retaliate they only had 30 minutes to
do this and so forth well I've been
looking into that and one of the things
I recommend looking at is it is not so
much that movie which maybe we're
looking at I don't know but anyway
there's a front line which is one of the
best you know practices the best thing
on television
in terms of documentaries in my view did
a program apart largely about that in
1999 called Russian roulette and they
have on their website the transcript of
the program they also have the
transcript of people they didn't put in
the program two generals one American
and one Russia now what they put in the
program is that the is total hysteria
namely we were within seconds of Yeltsin
pushing the button and retaliating
because he thought he'd been attacked
and they quote these two generals in the
program but they don't include what I'm
going to tell you now that's in the
outtakes and these two general said
there never was a chance of anything
going off what happens is that they have
these radar guys who are just you know
ordinary guys in the trenches and
they're watching stuff and they've got a
little checklist if you see this tell us
and one of the things they did was the
the United States was testing a missile
and they told us and some other stuff
and even they told the Russians that are
going to do so but the message never got
to the radar operators so the radar
operators are okay it's got this piece
going this way and this keeps going this
way we're you know we're not sort of
making any decisions we simply tell the
higher ups and that's what they did so
they told the higher ups and that
automatically activated a whole process
of things going all the way up to the
president boris yeltsin at the time so
at just a you know Santa precautionary
thing but there are several steps
between that in which people were
evaluating the evidence and according to
these two generals they figured out that
it was just a false alarm in tens of
seconds almost immediately they figured
out but that phrase front line did not
put in that program they have these two
journals both is that there wasn't any
danger and so this from you know really
good program that basically obviously
selling the notion that the nukes the
nukes are going to come from Russia at
any time from a mistake makes much more
it gets much more ratings than saying it
never was any danger so it's that kind
of thing that happens that Charles
Gibson or whatever you know
in essence of worth so the media
basically is in the position of
complicity in many respects but it's a
natural and natural as things scaring
people sells better than not scary it's
kind of a long answer to that but I you
know I think it illustrates the issue
it's been armor tie psychiatric social
worker and a long term lifelong peace
activists and I had a client who used to
say to me I know I'm paranoid but am i
paranoid enough and I think you know the
world is you know become that way and I
was here at the first one when James
stieber the wonders the assistant to
Hillary Clinton that was the first
lecture right and I'll repeat what I
said then that we care about the bang
but not the whimper we spent so much
money on the bang and not the whimper
and I'm going to quote this lovely guy I
was reading I picked up the CEPA thing
downstairs while I was waiting and
there's a lovely man who's part of that
program John Burnett he wrote this
article when he went to came back from
Haiti and I'll just quote him because
it's part of super and I think it's a
beautiful thing and this is what we
should think about but whatever you do
never forget that the human spirit is at
the fullest when we can look each other
in the heart and know that we share the
same inner light burning brightly in a
vast universe and I couldn't say it
better you know if we could only do that
instead of spending all the money on
bombs and hate we'd have a so thanks to
John Burnett who wrote that because
that's the way I felt my whole life yeah
let me extrapolate a little bit on that
during the course of the Cold War the
United States spent about 10 trillion
dollar between five and ten trillion
dollars on nuclear weapons weapons that
were designed to deter a threat that
didn't exist during that time there's
almost no examination in the academic
order of Defense community of wood the
Soviets really invade Western Europe a
few people I've looked hard when people
have said this and so that basically
this huge amount of money is being spent
and similarly we're doing it now on
Homeland Security to deal with a problem
which i think is really quite limited
thank you hello professor uh thank you
for thank you for coming um I have a
two-part question okay um my first
question is do you think an attack on
nuclear facilities is more likely than
an attack with with nuclear weapons and
my second question is related to jose
padilla who tried deploying the dirty
bomb do you uh you know a lot of news
outlets and new sources gave a lot of
information on television over the radio
about how to actually create a dirty
bomb right after Jose Padilla was
arrested and so my question to you is
what effect do you think that this
intense media coverage and this
distribution of information has on the
risk of a successful nuclear attack yeah
of those hurts okay late in the case of
nuclear reactors it's not clear that i
mean he i can imagine somebody trying to
attack a nuclear reactor and apparently
one of the women 911 planners work on
things they thought about slamming one
and two as which should be the targets
and one possibility was a nuclear
reactor it's basically it i think pretty
clear I've got got evidence and the book
that's coming up next April that even a
very large airliner couldn't do much
damage I mean he's this big concrete
containment structure so that and the
most it would do would potentially
release a relatively small amount of
radiation into the atmosphere which
probably wouldn't do much damage anyway
so it's not a very good target except
possibly symbolically from terrorist
standpoint I don't know the I don't know
what was a Padilla was talking thinking
about those charges of course about the
dirty bomb had been dropped that doesn't
mean they were based on something but
dirty bombs are very different from
nuclear explosions nuclear explosions
would kill people dirty bombs wouldn't
now I think that's a fairly important
thing people out to know and it would
but bothers me is you may remember about
two years ago there was a rumor that
someone's going to set off a bunch of
dirty bombs at national football
league's gains that Sunday and the media
sort of and the apartment security said
this is nonsense some guy in Wisconsin
not even in Arabic sin English not very
good English even but but but day but it
got reported in there sort of a feeding
frenzy on it and in the process what
happened was that the media never said
what I just said namely what had
happened if a dirty bomb went off well
if a dirty bomb went off in an NFL
stadium what would happen would be some
people might be killed by the explosion
the conventional explosion use of the
disperse the radioactivity but what
would happen would be the area would
then be quote contaminated unquote by
radiation so that if you stayed in the
stadium for 40 years non-stop by which
time you get very tired of hot dogs you
would increase your chance of getting
cancer by maybe one tenth of one percent
bad news is your chance of dying from
cancer now is already twenty percent so
you're not likely to notice in fact you
did no one had ever know because it'd be
lost in statistical noise so the point
is it would be an area that would be
contaminated by very conservative
standards and it might be money you'd
have to spend cleaning it up and so
forth but it wouldn't kill anybody and
the danger if a dirty bomb goes off its
people don't know that and so what they
do is trample each other getting out of
the way no one would say okay leave the
stadium you've got 40 years take your
time and but no one said that and the
media didn't you could even though this
is the bogus thing about the NFL
stadiums they're covering it but no one
said what would happen if one went off
and the answer is get up and walk calm
link to the exit and maybe something you
know maybe you want to take a shower and
burn your clothes or something you know
they probably don't you need to do that
but that's possibility and and so I
think that the possibility of dirty bomb
is far higher they're much easier than
nuclear weapon but the results are much
more limited in fact people when they
talk about it mostly say they're not
weapons of mass destruction their
weapons of mass disruption and that
seems to be pretty good way of looking
at it
hello thank you it's nice to hear that
the sky is not falling and I kind of
appreciate your very pragmatic you know
deflating of these you know overblown
kind of mass hysteria reactions to the
potential of nuclear threats but I do
think that there will be likely another
terrorist attack on American soil I mean
someone highly competent and highly
motivated will eventually succeed and
kill you know thousands of people I I
don't want that to happen but I just see
that it being likely which which kind of
terrorist threats to you as more
legitimate say than nuclear or chemical
biological dirty bombs things of that
nature yeah i'm certainly not saying
that the terrorists van won't happen of
course and because it terrorism so easy
by mean one guy i mean remember the guy
who killed 31 people at virginia tech a
few years ago with two pistols I mean it
wasn't terrorist he just sort of a crazy
kid but it's obviously very easy to do
that in this kind of situation so they
the one person can do it or a small
group can do it so I'd expect something
to happen something certainly could
happen it's just that if you look 911
still remains a total outlier there's
the biggest tag the tack that killed the
most people before that was a Air India
airliner that's blown up by some seek
terrorists in 1985 killed about 385
people that was the biggest attack there
and so there's a big thousands of people
is very hard to do and 911 you know I
don't want to downplay 911 was a
horrible thing but it still stands out
is totally spectacular and way out of
the out of the range of terrorist
attacks and robert muller the FBI guy
has said he's not you know he wants to
be worried about that he wants to be
worried about nuclear weapons he wants
to do something about his eyebrows but
he but he thinks the most likely thing
would be a bomb going off in a mall
maybe the thing like The Times Square
thing you can imagine somebody with hope
with presumably cannot hopefully but
with considerably better more brains in
capacity actually pulling it off but the
results are not you know they're going
to be some people killed and it's bad
and so forth it even the bombings in
London killed 52 people that's 52
but it's not you know not it's not the
end of the world so the possibility of
something like that happening is is
certainly there protecting against it is
very difficult because it can happen
they can change targets any minute and
so forth and so spending some worry time
worrying about it is ok but what I'd
like to do is keep it in context and you
know it is since nine eleven the United
States has spent over a trillion dollars
additional on Homeland Security spending
that does not include the wars in Iraq
and Afghanistan Justin mestic alee a
trillion 1.2 trillion dollars using
conservative estimates that's more than
the price of the Obama health care
setting so if that money didn't come to
the health care thing go how much it
could do and that's that's kind of way
you have to think about it the question
is should we how much money should we
spend reducing dangers that are already
extremely low 22 even lower and there's
there's no evidence that the terrorists
are getting better in terms of bigger
explosions I mean they've done tons of
damage obviously in Iraq but they're not
new those role basically the same level
if you look at there's three studies
that's just summarized what Islamic
extremists not necessarily Ida but
people look like them's think like them
admire them be her in the same category
how much how much damage is done by
Islamic extremists since nine eleven
throughout the whole world outside of
war zones and the total number of people
killed it comes to a few hundred a year
in the whole world now that's a few
hundred too many but it's an existential
threat to nobody and if we can get these
guys before they do it or after they do
it or whenever that's great but it's
sorry my book is called overblown not
non-existent and so so that's the
context i'd like to keep it in thank you
I think of a representation I'm a PhD
student here I find your points about
terrorism and probably hold ons and less
convinced proliferation but convincing
much less so though that the point that
is sort of reflecting the first line the
first green line about the absolute the
limited impact of nuclear weapons in
history and and relatedly the limited
military utility of nuclear weapons i
consent the first part of my concern the
fact that according to gervais recent
archival evidence suggests that the
Saudi Soviets were not aggressive does
not suggest that it would have been as
non aggressive in the absence of nuclear
weapons the second relatedly nuclear
weapons are supposed to be stabilizers
in situations in which both sides are
not aggressive but our afraid of the
other one being aggressive EG security
dilemma at above dynamics and so in fact
according to Gervais the worst
stabilizers unless he change his mind
compared to the earlier writings in
recent times ready to the military use
of nuclear weapons I just wanted to
point out something I'm Europe I'm sure
we're of like recent arguments by Lieber
and press and the same time one
empirical case that is the only known
case obviously I mean the only actual
case of user blcher weapons are
supposed to threats or bigger weapons
and there is a debate of course about
the partnership in where Hiroshima
Nagasaki idea about there's a little
debate about whether it was effective of
course but I mean reasonable arguments
I've been advanced by the fact that it
do I decide the use of weapon nuclear
weapons was decisive and the fact that
that kind of level destruction could
have been achieved with a conventional
weaponry doesn't mean that the fact that
it could be achieved with nuclear
weapons in the
it in a few seconds didn't make a
defense at least in terms of cost which
may might make a big difference in the
long work yeah let me just make you I I
deal with Hiroshima Nagasaki in a book I
didn't get into detail there is as
you're well aware this debate about
whether the bottoms are necessary
because the Soviets invaded at the same
time and so forth so what I said
basically it since world war two they
haven't had any impact that I'm able to
see we're very limited wanted certainly
in terms of Bob jurors thing about
stability leave it actually debated this
quite a bit I know you know we've like
gaddis we've been arguing about stuff
for decades and the I somewhat
uncomfortable the idea of stability and
destabilizing I mean essentially my
argument is that putting the you know
the man all j hughes before putting a
straight check out on a Quaker makes
things safer me is more stable but the
thing is that you have to consider what
it would have been without the
straitjacket so that essentially the
Soviet Union never in a billion years
wanted to do New World War two again
much less World War 2 plus nuclear
weapons I mean he just wasn't in their
game plan wasn't there thinking wasn't
it you know just craziness I mean they
wanted to subvert Western Europe using
labor unions and so forth they had plans
like that but getting into a frontal war
but is total crazy furthermore as Lenin
their their tactical genius you know or
guru was extremely careful about
confronting the capitalists in
imperialist world directly is always
basically making contradictions I mean
capitalism and capitalizing on them and
he's also extremely cautious about
tactics that you know two steps forward
one step back and groveling in the dirt
if necessary and moving the revolution
for it in ch by inch but never taking
huge risks because the danger is the
great respect for the imperialist in the
capitalist and that if you push them too
far they might just blow the whole world
up but he was worried about a collision
in which they would be attacked so so
their game plan never never really had
that in there so in retrospect my
argument i've used the argument there's
two kinds of thing crisis stability and
general stability and it seems to me
crisis stability means jurors talked
about that when he was here i look at it
the web basically if the crisis happens
you want it so that it doesn't escalate
but there's also things which is a
general stability which is the both
sides don't want anything to escalate no
matter what they don't even want to win
I mean in other words not getting rid of
the problem is more important than
winning in the issue and so therefore
they vastly prefer peace the even
fighting a war and winning because
they'd be worse off under winning and I
think that's been mostly the case in the
Cold War as it is obviously between the
United States and Canada or between
Germany and France now unfortunately I
think we're probably at the end of our
time here maybe John will stay around
for a couple minutes to answer some of
the questions but please join me in
thanking John for a thoughtful
you